the united states air force in
discharging its responsibility for the
aerospace defense of the nation is
called upon to investigate reports of
unidentified flying objects to air force
officers have over the years been very
closely associated a consecutive Jenna
Colonel Lawrence Taggart was formerly
the chief spokesman for the Air Force on
the matter and the major Hector
quintanilla is now the chief of project
little major quintanilla what are the
objectives that target uses the
objectives are the problem of too thin
they're the same as they have this is
lengthy 53 in the regulation of
different first of all to try to
determine if a beautiful phenomena
presents a threat to security and United
States in suckled to determine if the
youthful phenomena exhibits any
technological advances to the cannon
what's the record so far today we have a
with 10,000 cases of wright-patterson
Air future of what 646 of these and
women Jennifer that's not to say that we
could not have identified more cases if
we had gotten to do a very quickly they
touch the open our city the Air Force
has been accused in time to time of
hiding information about the UFO what do
you have to say to that contact police
charges are absolutely untrue actually
the United States Air Force releases
statistics on the UFO phenomena through
the Department of Defense press best
periodically and we've always honored
accredited media when they want to
investigate a given specific cited
there's nothing to have there's nothing
to hide at all is there anything in the
files either classified or unclassified
that would indicate that they're made
the extra-terrestrial visitors okay
first of all the project is completely
responsible and there is nothing in the
record to indicate that we have been
visited by any attention how does the
Air Force look upon people who make
reports of UFO they're not going to miss
qualify the trigger yes they do look on
them as qualified observers actually
most people who report a UFO sighting
are patriotic citizens who have been
mystified by something that they've seen
and through a patriotic sense reported
to the local law enforcement officials
or to the United States Air Force Base
near that what would you consider as a
person qualified to interpret what I see
why consider astronomers juin the
experts in their field first of all they
have a tremendous advantage over the
other physical scientists and that is
that they have powerful telescope and
photographic equipment to be permanent
your astronomical laboratories make any
contribution to the u.s. fulfilling in
the negative way they do because I
literally received the UFO reports in
another part not a one another soon well
how about the tracking and detective
facilities of the airport itself how
does this construct well actually to
begin with the United States Air Force
is charged by an act of congress with
the air defense of the United States in
the North American Air Defense Command
and the Air Defense Command has face
tracking facilities which are constantly
on nearly 24 hours a day we're
interested in anything that flies in our
atmosphere well how about UFO reports in
other countries how are they have a UFO
is actually occur worldwide however the
United States is the only country in the
world places as much emphasis on the
Konami other countries place a burden of
proof in the observing that on earth and
that would make your job a lot easier if
they did that mr. York Thank You Colonel
Parker major point Noah I would like to
close by reading a very brief excerpt
from the report of the Air Force's
scientific advisory board which they
made recently upon completing a detailed
review of the subject of UFO this is a
statement the committee concluded that
in the nineteen years since the first
UFO was sighted there has been no
evidence that unidentified flying
objects are threat to our national
security